as promised so there's a lot to unpack
from the democratic debate last night
four years ago Democrats came up with a
new and untested political theory they
could win the White House there
strategist promised if only they called
enough people racist that was the plan
Hillary Clinton for one thought it was
brilliant by election day she had
denounced fully half the country as
bigots in the end it did not work maybe
not surprisingly it turns out that when
you tell people you hate them they don't
care for it what voter strongly prefer
actually is when you try to improve
their lives it's not complicated
and yet somehow and this is the
remarkable part if you think about it
Democrats have in the three years since
they lost steadfastly refused to learn
this lesson improve people's lives
they'll tell you no thanks they think
their job is to improve people they
think voters are disgusting in a moral
they want to force them to be half as
virtuous as they are for the second
election cycle in a row that is the
Democratic message you're disgusting try
to be as good as we are
that message was on florid display last
night at the candidates debate watch to
pick just one among countless examples
of it as Washington governor jay Inslee
blames Americans for the coming end of
the world we could not work it out we
cannot work this out the time is up our
house is on fire we have to stop using
coal in ten years and when you're the
President to do it or it won't get done
that get off coal save this country and
the planet that's known for okay so
let's say carbon emissions really are
responsible for global climate change we
don't know that science has not proved
it sorry it is not but just for the sake
of argument let's stipulate that it's
true carbon causes climate change China
is by far the world's biggest emitter of
carbon so shouldn't Governor Inslee who
cares very deeply about climate change
turn his wrath on the Chinese well of
course but he didn't and never will
because for Democrats
everything is always the fault of
America's voters watch senator Kirsten
Gillibrand of New York brag about that
time she harangues some of the poorest
most desperate people in
erricka about how actually they're
privileged to privileged even as they
languish in chronic unemployment and
drop dead by the hundreds of thousands
from a widely ignored drug epidemic the
real problem kirsten gillibrand told
them is their white privilege I don't
believe that it's the responsibility of
kori and Kamala to be the only voice
that takes all these issues of
institutional racism systemic racism in
our country I think as a white woman of
privilege who is a US senator running
for president United States it is also
my responsibility to lift of those
voices that aren't being listened to and
I can talk to those white women in the
suburbs that voted for Trump and
explained to them what white privilege
actually is so my responsibility is to
not only lift up those stories but
explain to communities across America
like I did in Youngstown Ohio to a young
mother that this is all of our
responsibilities yeah they're privileged
in Youngstown that that's Youngstown's
problem just too much privilege not to
be outdone Julian Castro attacked
Americans for daring to complain about
illegal immigration to their country
open borders he explained is just a
right wing talking point and then a
single breath later Castro called for
repealing the law that makes it a crime
to enter America illegally watch open
borders is a right wing talking point
and frankly I'm disappointed
that some folks including some folks on
this stage have taken the bait the only
way that we're gonna guarantee that we
don't have family separations in this
country again is to repeal section 1325
of the immigration Nationality Act Cory
Booker meanwhile is in the process of
transitioning to a brand new identity he
spent most of the evening trying to
sound like a Nation of Islam recruiter
rather than the deeply privileged son of
two IBM executives which is what he is
there are people right now in prison for
life for drug offenses because you stood
up and use that tough-on-crime
phony rhetoric that got a lot of people
elected but destroy communities like
mine
it's Booker barking at the former vice
president
the best is communities like mine were
destroyed by you Joe Biden Cory Booker
grew up in Harrington Park New Jersey
the black population of Harrington Park
0.6% less than 1% the poverty rate for
families in Harrington Park is literally
zero not a single family in Harrington
Park is poor not one that's where Cory
Booker grew up so the only way that Joe
Biden's crime policies destroyed
Booker's hometown is by allowing its
residents to move out in gentrify
Brooklyn Cory Booker is by far the most
privileged candidate running for
president in either party this year and
that's fine it's not his fault
it's the relentless lying about it
that's so grating can any of these
candidates win a general election at
this point no they can't they're not
impressive enough Joe Biden was the
party's one real hope and after last
night it seems pretty clear conclusively
clear really that Uncle Joe is heading
for a well reserved retirement fact is
that the bills that the president that
excuse me that future president here
that that the senator is talking about
if you agree with me go to Joe 303 300
feet in this fight thank you very much
[Applause]
well I think it's time to forget about
making it to the White House Biden
couldn't even locate his own campaign
website that Joe 303 300 site doesn't
exist actually it's been bought by a
judge or something but it tells you a
lot about Joe Biden don't be fooled by
the current poll numbers Biden is
finished and if another can of doesn't
step up very soon and start talking like
a sane person so is the Democratic Party
at least for this cycle